what should I do
should I admit that I've made mistakes
should I remind you that I've done this
before
I'm LeBron James from Akron Ohio from
the inner city I'm not even supposed to
be here should I tell you I am NOT a
role mob hi Chuck
will he be better than Michael Jordan
will he be considered the greatest
player of all time when his career is
done LeBron James is by far our best
player in history let's take a moment to
pause and acknowledge what dis man is
doing and what he has been doing
what should I do
it's not really believe I wore my legs
what should I tell you a championship
chase beautiful money rings I've got
three not four
not by should I tell you how much fun we
yeah maybe I should just dissipate
what should I do it I'm beat you want me
to be a champion
what should I do Ron James the greatest
player in the world right now I don't
think anybody can question it I want to
get the greatest of all time that's my
the challenge to bring the championship
between because whoa
and hold and no matter when there's an
equal to 52 years
specialist or champion
retrograde
you're good
fire
James at the flutter
that's Oliver Cleveland is a city of
Champions once again the Cavaliers Oh
NBA champions the drought over fifty
years has finally ended you come at the
King you best not miss what should I do